then also for coming on food truck we
have a segment i do now where i give uh
all the fighters a pair of shoes i'm a
sneaker head okay yeah i know i know i
know you're a fashion guy yourself
so
with this one i got dude so this is what
i got dude yours yours made me nervous
so usually it's pretty easy i know where
to go with it but with you my boy mike
and suplex philly shout out to suplex
phil you're the one who'll provide all
the shoes okay they're like the sneaker
one stop shop suplex philly any shoes
you need these guys to get it done okay
so i tell them your story they know
you're like oh we love him like right so
but i was like he knows fashion dude so
we can't just give him like a random
pair of jordans something like that i go
we gotta get him like a unique pair
because he's a unique dude there's not a
lot of cleos out there in the world so
we got to get a pair that's rare because
you're a rare dude and these i don't
have these and we were the same size
shoe oh that says a lot dude when these
showed up in my house
you have another pair
they don't because they're very hard to
find oh my fragments fragment joints
they're so filthy oh my god
i might put them on now they are filled
one of my favorite shoes ever and
[Music]
that's my gift to you my man your
special dudes these are special shoes
wow special person yeah yeah i love you
man man yeah that's lovely for sure if
it's skinny but i need it
need a thick girl
i need everything i get super thick boy